certains disent qu'au fond le communisme
pourrait très bien d'être venir mais il
faudrait que le capitalisme souhaite
aller au bout d'abord c'est à dire qu'
il faudrait que le communisme peut
s'installer dans l'abondance qu'il ne
peut pas le faire dans la pénurie
qu'en pensez-vous vous vous êtes un
défenseur de l'hypothèse communiste oui
mais je pense qu'il ya je pense qu'il ya
une vérité là dedans mais elles m'ont
ont un de mes maîtres au communisme qui
a été fait et elle tu sers le philosophe
althusser disait souvent qu'il fallait
pas il fallait pas oublier que la partie
fondamentale ne se jouer certainement
pas à cuba ou peut-être même pas en
chine et peut même pas en russie
finalement mais dans les grandes
métropoles qui sont les piliers du
capitalisme lui-même que c'était là que
ça devait se passer je serai c'est
d'accord je serais assez d'accord le
destin de l'humanité toute entière ne se
décidera pas sa périphérie
la moins avancée dans les constructions
néolithique donc ce qu'il faut c'est que
nous inventions que nous tentions de
créer un nouveau communiqué le garde le
mot parce que parce que j'en ai pas
trouvé d'autre amodu avec abu appropriée
est capable de s'enraciner y compris
dans les métropoles l'impérial résultats
de de plusieurs siècles de construction
à
[Musique]